- I'm a rapper.
Right, You didn't know that.
You didn't.
No, you'd be forgiven for not knowing it,
but I am a rapper.
I do freestyle rap.
That means rap that you make up.
It's not written or prepared,
it's improvised in the moment,
will only be seen now by you guys
and never be repeated again.
What would you like to hear a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Getting hit by a bus.
- Getting hit by a bus.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Has that ever happened
to you in your life?
I can't see.
Are you in a wheelchair?
I can't see, like?
No.
(audience laughing)
Being hit by a bus.
Okay, great. I love it.
Great, people over here.
Front to the back,
but this wedge here
what should I rap about?
- [Audience Member] Bulgarian princess.
- There were two, so you said
Bulgarian Princess, is that true?
And then behind you?
- [Audience Member] Coked
up Canadian ski jumper.
- A coked up Canadian ski jumper?
Yeah. Great.
A coked up Canadian ski jumper
and a Bulgarian princess
being hit by a bus.
So far these are great suggestions.
Okay, we're gonna have
to, 'cause there's only
two more suggestions left,
we're gonna have to kind of
make it more so all kind of,
this front section and this side section.
What's the next suggestion gonna be?
- Monkey surgeon on vacation.
- Bestiality.
- Iraq war.
- Okay, so there were three,
but you wait, you waited the longest, sir.
And so what happened was the person said,
monkey surgeon on vacation
and we were all like, is
it a surgeon who operates
on monkeys or is the monkey a surgeon?
Someone said bestiality.
We were like to people fuck
the monkey who's a surgeon.
And then you came through just waiting
with Iraq War and everyone loved that.
Everyone loved it.
So, that's pretty fun.
And then people in this
section, but at the back,
what do you wanna rap about?
- [Audience Member] Kanye
pitching at Skechers.
- [Audience Member] Jerry Sandusky.
- Okay. Okay.
There were two.
So did you say it was Kanye
and then you said Skechers.
So was it Kanye working with Skechers?
Okay, cool 'cause Adidas
have dropped him 'cause
he's an anti-Semite.
And then you said Jerry Sandusky, which,
and then everyone laughed,
which makes me think that's a bad person.
Okay.
Would someone be willing to tell me
who Jerry Sandusky is from the front row?
Why'd you look?
- [Audience Member] He
was a coach at Penn State.
- [Audience Member] Pedophile.
- He was a coach at Penn
State who raped children.
What a fun rap topic.
What a really fun.
The problem is, like Kanye
has been coming up a lot recently.
People are always like, rap about that
and I'm kind of sick
about giving it air time.
So Jerry Sandusky it is.
So these are the topics, right?
A coked up Canadian ski
jumper getting hit by a bus.
A Bulgarian princess, Jerry Sandusky,
who's a coach at Penn
State, who raped children.
Were they actual children or teenagers?
Teenagers. Okay.
'Cause there's a difference
between pedophilia
and hebephilia no, like
a syntactical difference.
The Greeks.
A pedophile is someone
who fancys children.
And a hebephile is someone
who fancys post pubescent children.
So I studied Greek, right?
They fucked a lot of kids
and they wanted you to know.
People are like, you fuck kids?
They'll be like, yeah,
I'm a pedophile, right?
And if you said that they, you know
the Greeks were very.
In the past, not modern day Greeks.
I'm not saying, I'm not saying that.
Okay. I love Masaka.
Don't, you know.
And then the final one was the Iraq War.
Okay.
Tell you what, band, can we make it?
Can we make it like, kind of more chill?
And that doesn't mean slow, but more like
I don't know if it's
like soulful or laid back
because I feel like going in super agro
on the whole child fucking
bit will be really upsetting,
but if we like make it a
bit cooler and smoother
people will be like, yeah, you know,
it's distasteful, but it bops.
It's a strategy very
much pursued by R Kelly.
I think it really works.
It really, you can kind of, you know.
My dream is to have the
Jamaican lady going,
pop, pop, pop, pop.
That's what I want.
That's what I, that's my dream.
If this rap ends with you, just go.
(mimicking machine gun)
Okay. Okay.
♪ I've gotta prove myself,
making sure you trust me ♪
♪ Starting with something
else, but move to Sandusky ♪
♪ A lady who's busty,
where she's coming from ♪
♪ I'll share with you ♪
♪ Oh, hello ♪
♪ A lady from Bulgaria ♪
♪ I'm walking in ♪
♪ Yes, I impress ♪
♪ Large breasts ♪
♪ Large diamonds ♪
♪ You know that I'm a princess ♪
♪ I say wow, 10 out at 10 complete ♪
♪ Even though you sound like
the Count from Sesame Street ♪
♪ It's kind of confusing. ♪
♪ Maybe you could wedge me ♪
♪ bring the houses together,
the royalty Messi, me and you ♪
♪ I go on holiday, she shows up ♪
♪ Got an instructor
Canadian, he's coked up ♪
♪ He says we're gonna learn ♪
♪ the ski jumping, ski wood chalet ♪
♪ Me and her pumping humping, loving it ♪
♪ But this fellow Canadian
guy who loves snow and blow ♪
♪ Well technically that's
a different type of snow ♪
♪ No mistake ♪
♪ Take the cocaine in a large line ♪
♪ He snakes, he's left or right ♪
♪ like a slalom skier, you know, I see ♪
♪ But he's moving so high
like the veritable eagle ♪
♪ That's the bird that
symbolized the nation ♪
♪ Went back to Iraq twice ♪
♪ That's infatuation the first one ♪
♪ George Bosnia. ♪
♪ Then the sun was like, hey ♪
♪ I might be teenier, but I'm going in ♪
♪ I'm going to get Saddam Hussein ♪
♪ Even though we put him in
power in the first place ♪
♪ It's ironic you really wanted it ♪
♪ I won't spoil saying
there's nuclear warheads now ♪
♪ Just oil ♪
♪ You lied like psych, we
were making up reports ♪
♪ Go and get Saddam,
hanging when he was caught ♪
♪ Head separated from his
body capital punishment ♪
♪ They did it shoddy ♪
♪ But I'll do it properly ♪
♪ I'm a monkey surgeon ♪
♪ I've got an urge to walk in here ♪
♪ Yeah I fix it ♪
♪ I serve them a real person, a man ♪
♪ Not the ape ♪
♪ I make sure that their
tendons get fixed ♪
♪ No mistake ♪
♪ And while I'm there, an urge grabs me ♪
♪ The surgeon of the monkey
wants to practice Bestiality ♪
♪ And all the other nurses ♪
♪ And anesthetists say that's illegal ♪
♪ Surgeon will see to
this, release from this ♪
♪ Yeah, I'm moving on ♪
♪ Went to Penn State ♪
♪ Oh, I feel I'm proving on
someone already screamed like ♪
♪ Please no, don't say many
raps about Jerry Sando ♪
♪ That's what I call him ♪
♪ Like we're on ♪
♪ The first name terms, he
picked out his favorite ♪
♪ Ones of all the first term athletes ♪
♪ He gets them on the bench ♪
♪ He says, ah, I want to get
you in a kind of clench ♪
♪ In a passionate lock. ♪
♪ Look, when push comes to
shove, surely it's improper ♪
♪ But maybe he's in love ♪
♪ Maybe he was a groomer,
I assume, but okay ♪
♪ He steps out of the conference room ♪
♪ And says, I'm going to escape ♪
♪ No one will know ♪
♪ He walks right down the
street, that Jerry fellow ♪
♪ People say, Jerry, you're a ♪
♪ Horrible person in front of us ♪
♪ And what's the justice served? ♪
♪ He gets hit by a fucking bus. ♪
(audience cheering)